Welcome back everyone happy spider-man week
this is going to be my spider-man freshman year
breakdown video marvel just announced a brand
new spider-man disney plus series for all of
you who've been asking for one if you're brand new
to the channel of course i'll be doing videos for
that series when the episodes start releasing
so be sure to subscribe to get everything
and we have our big spider-man no way home
trailer coming this week finally it is like
spider-man o'clock on the internet right
now am i not supposed to have what i want
what i need i'm doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and just let me know which villains
you want to see spider-man fight during spider-man
freshman year but this past week during disney
plus day marvel released a whole bunch of disney
plus trailers and teasers for upcoming shows that
they're doing as well as announcements for other
shows that they've just started working on like
the brand new x-men the animated series episodes
that they're working on i'm sure everyone is just
hearing the music playing in their heads while
i'm talking about this some of the stuff they
announced was legit amazing but while all this
craziness was happening marvel also announced
that they're doing a new mcu spider-man disney
plus series called spider-man freshman year there
was a lot of confusion about what it's going to be
about what the story will be and which version
of spider-man it's going to feature because
there have been a lot of rumors about sony and
marvel using the next spider-man movie trilogy to
introduce live-action miles morales spider-man but
just to clarify spider-man freshman year is going
to be an animated disney plus series based on tom
holland's mcu spider-man set during the events of
his freshman year at midtown high because if you
remember the first time we saw him during captain
america civil war when iron man came to recruit
him he was already 16 years old and in his second
year of high school he'd already been spider-man
for a while spider-man homecoming was just set
later during that school year spider-man far from
home was set during his junior year his third year
for those outside the united states the timeline
got a little wonky because of avengers infinity
war avengers endgame the snap the blip with that
five year time jump all those kids basically had
to repeat their third year of high school and
the timeline just got crazy but they played it
for a big joke at the beginning of spider-man far
from home even though we had blipped away halfway
through the school year and had already taken
midterms the school made a start the whole year
over from the beginning spider-man no way home
is set during his senior year the final year of
high school like the whole idea kevin feige said
when they first started doing the tom holland
mcu spider-man movies was that they would do the
harry potter thing following him through each year
of school but the idea is that we never really got
to see him be spider-man during his freshman year
and if you haven't read a lot of the classic
spider-man comics or he have been a longtime
spider-man fan he became spider-man when he was a
freshman when he turned 15 he got the spider bite
uncle ben died that year everyone cued the big
speech that's also the year that he created
the homemade costume the mcu version of the
homemade costume we kind of got a teaser for
that during captain america civil war when iron
man was pulling all those youtube clips of him
that's you right um no what are you what are you
doing look at you go wow nice catch 3000 pounds 40
miles an hour it's not easy you got mad skills
that's uh that's all on youtube though right
a lot of those clips would have been posted
during his freshman year when he was still
figuring out how his powers worked and learning to
be a superhero so for everyone who wanted to see
what was going on with mcu uncle ben or wondered
what the deal with him was we'll probably get to
see a version of him during the series the first
episode will probably start with the story of
him getting the spider bite and getting the great
power great responsibility speech from uncle ben
but if it wasn't clear this isn't going to be just
a limited series they will do multiple seasons
and it's called spider-man freshman year because
however many seasons it goes it will always be set
during the events of his freshman year so it's
not like the first season will cover his entire
freshman year it'll just cover the first part of
it most of you probably done the math on this the
show will probably cover most of that first act of
the original tobey maguire spider-man movie in the
andrew garfield's amazing spider-man movie like
we'll see a version of mcu tom hall and spider-man
doing the wrestling match from the comics uncle
ben will probably die somewhere towards the end of
the first season we'll see him make the homemade
costume make his original mechanical web shooters
make his original web formula a lot of the
montages that we got with tobey maguire and
andrew garfield's versions of spider-man which
is done over the course of eight to ten episodes
the episodes will be about the same length of the
marvel what-if episodes and about the same number
of episodes per season but the animation style
is going to be different unless i'm mistaken
too the way they designed this teaser for the
logo here with the original steve ditko art i
think the style of the series will be leaning
into that animation style like it will look a
little bit like it's inspired by steve ditko's
original art but it'll be 3d animation so if it
wasn't clear it won't look like the animation
from what if but it will still be 3d animation
just like the other marvel disney plus series some
of the movie actors will come back to play their
characters it'll basically be the same characters
from spider-man homecoming and spider-man far from
home like all the same kids that he goes to high
school with in the mcu the only thing they haven't
announced is who those villains are going to be
for the initial season because he didn't fight the
vulture for example till the events of spider-man
homecoming so a lot of the classic sinister six
villains he didn't really encounter until that
sophomore year but recently you've probably seen
a lot of rumors about the upcoming new trilogy
in your timeline so the big rumor right now is
that marvel and sony's plans for the future
of the spider-man character just in general
are that after spider-man no way home tom holland
continues to be spider-man in spider-man stays in
the mcu like sony and marvel renew their sharing
deal for more movies they'll do a new trilogy
story arc following him through his college
years and they'll use that to also introduce
live-action mcu miles morales he already exists
we just haven't heard about him or seen him since
before the snap in fact if you didn't realize
there was a spider-man homecoming deleted scene
that featured a bigger miles morales name drop
like legit miles morales it's pretty ballsy
i don't want those weapons in this neighborhood
i got a nephew who live here excuse me
a human being needs help
he just do man yeah sorry miles i'm not gonna make
it yeah i'm just stuck early theory about that too
they'll use the snap to age him up five
years faster and he'll be a freshman
in high school when we see him on screen for the
first time and we'll watch him get his spider bite
and tom holland spider-man will serve as a mentor
to him if you've seen the recent interviews with
tom holland saying that he would love to come
back and mentor future quote-unquote versions
of spider-man that's basically what he was talking
about mentoring a version of live-action mcu miles
morales eventually and supposedly their plan is
to have this spider-man freshman year tv series
sort of fill in the gaps between major spider-man
movies they usually release new major spider-man
movies every two years so like in the year where
there's no spider-man movie you get another season
of the spider-man freshman year tv series but it
would be mcu spider-man it sounds like we'll get
season one of the episodes during 2023 that's also
the same year that they plan on releasing the new
x-men the animated series episodes as well if you
remember marvel zombies from marvel's what if tv
series they also confirmed that they're doing a
spin-off show just for marvel zombies i'm assuming
the animation style will also be a little bit
different for that too so they'll just creatively
retune it just a little but it'll be based on
the marvel zombies that you saw during what if
it has been rumored that because the show is all
about tom hall and spider-man in his freshman
year that he'll come back to do the episodes
but he didn't come back to do spider-man for
the marvel what if series it was a different actor
last year mr stark asked me to join the avengers
i turned him down and now they're all gone and i'm
still here so they could always wind up getting
a different actor because it's set during his
freshman year he's going to sound way younger
so it would be easy to justify getting someone
who sounds younger than tom holland but i think
the idea is they're going to try and get him to
come back to do the episodes and since the show
is set in the mcu like i said it's all connected
to everything his freshman year was fall 2014
to summer 2015. that means the show is going to
overlap with the events of avengers age of ultron
captain america winter soldier took place while
he was still in middle school like he was still
in eighth grade when that was happening before
he started his freshman year at midtown high
in the events of iron man 3 and the first ant-man
movie didn't start till after he'd finished his
freshman year so really the only movie that we're
overlapping with is avengers age of ultron but you
have to remember that the avengers had been living
in the avengers tower going on missions around
the world just cleaning up smaller messes for a
couple years when avengers age of ultron picked up
so while mcu peter parker was finishing middle
school starting at midtown high he would have
been watching clips of the avengers saving people
and taking down villains all over the world for
like the previous year or two mcu spider-man
was supposed to have grown up admiring all these
different heroes that's why after they introduced
mcu spider-man they retconned it so that this
little kid in the iron man mask was supposed to
be a younger version of his character even though
in real life the actual actor who was playing
this underneath the mask was john favreau's son
in real life but hopefully that explains what's
going on with the show they'll reveal more details
and more footage as they start to finish that
but they just started working on it like i said
probably not going to premiere till 2023 the real
big thing this week is the next spider-man no way
home trailer that's coming on tuesday of course
i will do all the videos for that make sure you
enable alerts for my channel to be the first to
watch that everyone click here for that brand
new marvel moon knight trailer video in easter eggs
and click here for that brand new she-hulk trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!